I'm Todd nice to meet you what's your
name nice to meet you let me guess
actors my name is Jonathan Todd Harris
but when I moved to LA there was an
agent named Todd Harris and we would get
each other's phone calls all the time so
uh I actually decided to invoke my first
initial to differentiate Roli and
actually I figured out in colleges i
liked producing i realized i wasn't
gonna be an actor as much as I liked and
I didn't have the discipline I don't
think I had the toughness for all the
rejection not the producing doesn't have
projection like a sentence yeah only
once in this is almost needed okay for
exactly to be better my name I'm working
on it I got a job in between years at
business school and most people were
doing you know thousand dollar a week
jobs at Morgan Stanley I was down here
reading screenplays the so long ago I
used to write my coverage by hand and
then type it up on my manual typewriter
and fix my mistakes with whiteout I
spent some years getting my sea legs and
I finally found a script called Denise
calls up it was a high-concept
low-budget film about seven people whose
lives intersected in every conceivable
way they made love that gave birth they
died but they never met cuz it all took
place on the phone so it was a really
unique independent film we made it for
six hundred thousand dollars it got into
the Cannes Film Festival into critics
week it was a exhilarating thing that
sort of setting the emotional eating
other independent films and I got a
couple more films in the Sundance why
don't I like you cuz you think I'm an
also and I'm not really i'm just British
and huh you're not the last movie I had
at Sundance cuz the kids are alright one
of the producers came to me and said can
you help us raise this money we need
this money we're starting this movie in
2-3 months i love the script i was able
to find an investor who came in really
relatively quickly and easily and boom
it was ahead
each of my moms had a kid with your
sperm like in both of them uh-huh like
in gay writer hunt oh I love lesbians
great I got it what's become clear is
the prevalence that brands have in the
entertainment marketplace you know it's
not just Batman spider-man Iron Man
Superman it's things that you wouldn't
have thought of 10 or 15 years ago like
a dusty old toy called transformers from
the 70s we're surrounded by them their
books their games their toys that are
plays five years ago a friend of mine
said to me what do you think about
Heather's as a musical and I thought wow
that's a crazy idea we've been working
on it for five or six years tonight is
our first fully staged production this
is our chance for investors to see the
show right here in our backyard a lot of
people are flying out from New York to
see it I really feel like we might have
you know the next hairspray or the
spring awakening or something something
special
it's the Wild West there's so many
exciting brands out there that I think
that you know some of them are
appropriate for TV some of them are
appropriate for theater something
appropriate for the movies some from web
development and a big part of producing
is going out and getting exciting
intellectual property and controlling it
and adding value to it señoras this is a
nonsense thees EES Montek are my advice
about getting into the film business is
like most businesses you're gonna do you
should really want to do it and if
you're gonna get in I would leave in one
of my only regrets is that it took me
seven years of living in LA to finally
make a movie I spent out you know four
or five years partying around and trying
and thinking and hoping and praying but
you know these days if you really want
to make a movie and you really
understand the economics of it and the
mechanics of it it's really accessible
to make a movie and you can make a movie
for a few hundred thousand dollars if
you go about it the right way there are
a lot of people who talk about it to
think about it and want it but I think
the people who actually get off their
ass and do it you know like most things
you just you know like Nike said just do
it
you
you